The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
MICHAEL SHORT:
Well, as promised,
we're gonna cover no
new material today.
We've just hit the end of
part two of the course,
which I think you'll
agree with me,
was probably the most
technically challenging part.
Who would disagree, I wonder?
I didn't think so.
So I wanted a bit of review and
help you guys out with problem
set seven.
Since I've got a
couple of fun problems,
I think they're fun
because they're actually
fairly realistic, like the
last one, will it blend,
the AP 1000 edition.
Well, you'll actually analyze if
given the actual specification
sheet of an AP1000
reactor, which
is a modern reactor that's
being built now, can
you determine it's k-effective
using the the two energy group
approximation.
And just to show you guys
that this isn't crazy,
I've got the AP1000
spec sheet up here.
So who got a chance to
take a look at p-set seven?
Good, that's a lot of hands.
All right, I highly
recommend everyone look
at it ahead of time.
Because it is the
doozy, and it will be
the last doozy of this course.
So part three of the
course is lighter.
Because most of
your other courses
are going to go nuts after
Thanksgiving, as far as I know,
right?
Yeah, this one's not.
So I'm doing my best to
equalize your total course
load this semester by
making this course crazy now
and lighten up when
final season comes.
AUDIENCE: The real MVP.
MICHAEL SHORT: So I've got the
spec sheet for the AP1000 right
here.
That actually goes
over a description
of what the core is
like, the materials that
are used, how many
fuel rods there are,
how many assemblies
there are, basically
what the core is made of.
And what I want to do is jump
to the end where they actually
talk about the analytical
techniques used
in the core design.
And what I want to show you
is for the nuclear design
of the core to get axial
power distributions,
look at that, two-group
diffusion theory.
The same stuff that we
just learned right here.
For axial power
distribution control rod
worth's one-dimensional
two-group diffusion theory--
these are problems that you
can solve with the stuff
that we've done over the
past week and a half.
They have a little
more complexity
in that they keep all the
spatial variance in there.
So probably done with
computers, however they
make the same
equations that you do.
So Westinghouse is making
the same assumptions
that we made in this course.
They have a lot more
complexity in that they're--
you know, we just
had cross sections
or a macroscopic cross sections
as a function of energy,
but you may also think about
it as a function of position
and a function of
temperature, since,
as we started alluding to, on--
it wasn't today-- on
Wednesday-- no, Tuesday.
What day is it now?
It's Thursday.
Thank you, so it was
definitely on Tuesday.
We started talking about
how cross sections change
with temperature.
And so really if we want to go
crazy on that neutron transport
equation, these
cross sections will
be functions of energy,
temperature, and position.
And so that's how this
reactor would have actually
been designed.
But you're going to do
a simpler approximation
and take all of the information
about the core in an AP1000,
blend it, so homogenize
it, figure out
what the average
atomic fractions of all
the different things in
it are, and calculate
its k-effective, which I think
is a pretty cool problem to do.
I haven't seen it done
in the courses here.
But I want to see
how it turns out.
And you might find
it's surprisingly
different from one.
Because we make a lot a
lot of simplifications
that actually
matter quite a bit.
But to help you parse
this spec sheet,
well, actually why don't I
show you the problem first.
And we'll go through a few
of the different things
that I've simplified the problem
to make it not so tedious.
But I also want to make sure
you understand what to do.
So the simple statement
is calculate k-effective
of the AP1000 using two-group
diffusion theory, which
means you've got a
criticality condition
from the two-group
approximation.
And I'd like to go over
what that is right now.
So let's write out, if
we had a two group--
so we have two energy
group equations
for gains and losses of neutrons
in the fast and thermal group.
What would it look like?
What are the gain terms?
AUDIENCE: Sigma
[INAUDIBLE] fast.
MICHAEL SHORT: Yep.
There's going to be some
average nu times sigma
fission fast times
flux fast plus sigma
fission thermal
times flux thermal.
Any other sources of
neutrons into the fast group?
I don't think so.
What about sinks?
How do neutrons
leave the fast group?
AUDIENCE: Absorption.
MICHAEL SHORT:
Yep, by absorption.
How else?
AUDIENCE: Scattering.
MICHAEL SHORT: Yeah,
scattering from the fast
to the thermal group.
How else?
AUDIENCE: Leakage.
MICHAEL SHORT: Leakage.
So there'll be some
diffusion constant fast times
some fast geometric
buckling squared.
And, yeah, I think that's it.
No, that needs a
phi as well fast.
OK, cool.
What about the thermal group?
What are the sources
of thermal neutrons?
AUDIENCE: Scattering.
MICHAEL SHORT: Yep, scattering
from the fast group.
So this same term right here.
Fast to thermal times phi fast.
And what are the losses?
AUDIENCE: Leakage
and absorption.
MICHAEL SHORT: Leakage
and absorption, they
look pretty familiar.
Thermal phi, thermal plus D
thermal Bg squared phi thermal.
And that's a "t."
OK.
The hard part in
this problem is going
to be doing these averages.
This is the part that we haven't
explicitly done on the board
and I want to show you.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Are those Ts
or Fs, the first term
of the second half.
MICHAEL SHORT: This one?
AUDIENCE: The top equation.
MICHAEL SHORT: The top equation.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, right there.
MICHAEL SHORT: Uh,
that should be a--
I'll make the Fs really curly.
Curly.
And those are straight Ts.
These are curly Fs.
OK, great, thank you.
So the hard part is going to be
doing cross section averages.
We've just kind of written
them as, hey, they're
average cross sections.
And an average
cross section would
look something like the
integral from a minimum
to a maximum of the cross
section as a function of energy
times the flux over
the same integral
without the cross section.
This is where I want
to point out something
that I want you to remember
for the rest of this course
and the rest of your life.
You don't have to do
things analytically
if you don't want to,
unless it's explicitly
stated that you have to.
So part of this piece, that
is to drill in the idea
that it's the future,
we have computers.
And you can do numerical
integration with data.
Remember on one of the
second problem sets,
I showed you guys the
web plot digitizer?
How you can extract information
from a printed graph?
Well, a lot of times,
what you'll already have
is that data.
And you'll have
to then integrate
that numerically in
something as simple as Excel
or as complicated as
Matlab or something worse--
whatever tool you choose to use.
I'll be using Excel because
it's kind of the lowest
common denominator.
And so to show
you guys you don't
need to know any fancy
software to actually solve
these problems.
So let's go through getting
some of this data right now.
Let's say that the cutoff
between fast and thermal--
so if we were doing a
fast cross section--
the cutoff would be at 1 eV.
And our max would be,
let's say, 10 MeV,
which would be the top
of the fission birth
spectrum or the chi spectrum.
1 eV, and that would be 10 MeV.
So all that's left is
you need tabulated values
for the cross sections
and the fluxes.
And then you can perform
this numerical integral.
I have given you tabulated
values for the fluxes, wherever
that is.
Yep.
Use the attached AP1000
tabulated neutron flux profile,
which opens, that's awesome.
So I've given you the
approximate neutron flux
in neutrons per
centimeter squared
per second as a function
of neutron energy.
And so you can tell
for low neutron energy,
there aren't any ultra-cold
neutrons in this problem,
though there are in the
problem right before.
Because, remember,
the "we'll see?"
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MICHAEL SHORT: Now
is when we'll see.
But if we scale down, we get
down to the thermal regions
where it's in the eV levels.
You start to see pretty
significant neutron fluxes
in the realm of 10 to the
14 neutrons per centimeter
squared per second.
So that value of 10 to
the 14 for flux that we've
been using in all
our previous problem
sets-- it's because that's
what we actually get.
This flux spectrum and the
picture of it that we have here
was taken from the MIT reactor
because it's representative
of a pressurized water reactor.
The only difference here
is this is the spectrum
from the fast flux trap.
You don't usually see
that fast to thermal ratio
in a thermal reactor.
But it's the closest
spectrum that I was easily
able to get my hands on.
And it's not that
unrepresentative.
And the reaction
rates for things
aren't going to
be that different.
Because most of
the reaction rates,
the cross sections down
here are in the, like,
thousands of barns level.
And the cross sections here
are in the one-barn level.
It's pretty much any fast
cross section for anything
it's about a barn.
That's a good rule of thumb.
So it's not going to change
total reaction rates that much.
And that's why I'm not worried
about taking the fast flux
spectrum from the MIT
reactor and pretending like
it's the AP1000's.
It's not horribly that far off.
And it's at the right order of
magnitude, which is important.
So that data, I give you.
Let's talk about how
to get this data--
the macroscopic cross sections.
So if you remember, a
macroscopic cross section
is a microscopic cross section
times a number density.
And that's for one
single isotope.
If you have a mix of
isotopes, then your total
averaged cross section for
all different types of atoms
is going to be a sum--
I'll make it very different--
over all your possible
isotopes of the atom fraction
of that isotope times the number
density of that isotope times
the microscopic cross section of
that reaction for that isotope.
Or, I'm sorry, the
atom fraction is
included in the number density.
Let's just simplify
this a little bit.
The total number density
of that isotope--
that'll be in atoms
per cubic centimeter--
times the cross section for
that particular isotope,
which is in centimeters
squared, which leads you to a 1
over centimeter
macroscopic cross section.
And so let's say we were
summing up something
like stainless steel,
which happened to be iron
18 chrome 10 nickel.
Not only would you
have to then get
the number densities of
iron, chrome, and nickel,
but you have to look at
which isotopes there are.
So if we wanted to get
the macroscopic cross
section for
stainless steel, we'd
have to split this into the
stable isotopes of iron,
the stable isotopes of chrome,
and the stable isotopes
of nickel and then
say it's this number
density times a cross
section plus this number
density times a cross section,
and so on and so on and so on.
The easy way to get
those number densities,
if you take the number density
of your stainless steel
times the atom fraction of that
isotope, that should give you
the number density
of that isotope.
Does this make
sense to everybody?
Does anyone not know how to get
a number density of a material
from its basic
chemical properties?
OK.
So a number density is in
atoms per cubic centimeter.
And usually we
would have something
like its density, which would
be grams per cubic centimeter.
So if we take density in
grams per centimeter cubed
and multiply by Avogadro's
number and divide by--
I'll just put a
divide-by symbol here--
the molar mass--
Avogadro's number is
given in atoms per mole--
and divide by-- molar
mass units are given in--
what is it-- grams per mole--
so that's going to be
like moles per gram.
The grams cancel,
the moles cancel,
and you get atoms
per cubic centimeter.
So to get a number density,
you can take the density
of the material-- you know,
for stainless steel it's like 8
grams per cubic centimeter--
times Avogadro's number-- let's
say 6 times 10 to the 23rd,
and this would be like 8 grams
per centimeter cubed or so--
divided by the molar
mass or the average molar
mass of stainless steel.
I'm guessing that's
around 56 grams per mole.
And then you'll get
a number density.
And typical solid
number densities
tend to range from like 10
to the 26 to 10 to the 28.
It'll be atoms per meter cubed.
So it's going to be around,
like, 21 to 23 atoms
per centimeter cubed.
So if you end up with something
way outside those bounds,
you've probably got some
sort of unit or power error.
So that'll help
you check your math
to make sure you get the
number densities right.
If you get the number
densities right
and you know the atom
fractions, then you
have the number
density of each isotope
in the number of atoms of that
isotope per cubic centimeter.
And then you multiply by your
microscopic cross section
and you get your
macroscopic cross section.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Could
you explain again
what atom fraction refers to?
MICHAEL SHORT:
Yeah, atom fraction
is a fraction between
0 and 1 of what
proportion of the atoms in
your material are that isotope.
So again, if you're
atom fractions
are outside the
bounds of 0 to 1,
that's not physically
significant.
If your number densities are
really far from those bounds,
then they're
probably not right--
unless you're talking about
a gas or a neutron star.
But solid matter tends to have
approximately those number
densities.
Mm-hm?
AUDIENCE: Since we're
putting this reactor
in a blender [INAUDIBLE].
MICHAEL SHORT: Mm-hm.
AUDIENCE: So when we
[INAUDIBLE] the atom
fractions to do
these calculations,
how would we determine
the fractions?
MICHAEL SHORT: Good question.
You'll determine those fractions
from the AP1000 spec sheet.
So in the AP1000 spec
sheet, it tells you
things like total weight of
the fuel as uranium dioxide.
And so you can go from total
weight of the fuel to, let's
say, molar or atom
fraction of the fuel.
If you know the weight
of the fuel-- it's nice,
they give you the
weight of the fuel.
They give you the
weight of the clad.
And let's see,
which materials did
we say you have to think about?
It said you have to talk
about four materials;
the coolant or the
moderator-- water; the fuel--
UO2; the clodding-- where you
can assume pure zirconium,
forget all the crazy zircaloids
because that's just busy work;
and structural materials--
assume pure iron.
And so on this spec
sheet, luckily, they just
tell you the mass of the fuel.
They tell you the
mass of the clad.
I do not believe they give
you the mass of the water,
but they do give you
the volume of the core.
And so you can figure
out, if you've got a core
and you subtract off
the volume of the fuel
and the cladding and the
structural materials,
all you're left with is volume
of the water in the core.
And that'll give you your
total weight of the water.
And once you have
all the weights,
then you can go
to atom fractions.
And then you've got
all the information
you need to get the
macroscopic cross sections.
Is that unclear to anybody?
Cool.
So we talked about
how to get the N's.
Let's show you how
to get the sigmas.
So there was a comment that came
in that said please teach us
how to use these databases.
We just kind of
throw them around.
Well, I want to teach you
how to use this database.
Let's say we're going to get
the cross sections for oxygen
in uranium dioxide.
That's nice and easy because
there's only one stable isotope
of oxygen you have to consider.
It's oxygen 16.
I highly recommend using
the Java version of JANIS
because it is a
lot easier to use,
less clunky, and more intuitive.
So if you don't have Java on
your machine-- first of all,
it runs on everything, like
phones, tablets, Linux, Mac,
Windows whatever.
And second of all, it'll
just make your life easier.
So a little time investment now
will make the p-set take less.
So once you have Java, it
should just open cleanly.
And it may show up with nothing.
It may show up with
something, depending
on what you last looked at.
In this case, it's looking
at whatever last library
I looked at.
So let's pretend
we're starting over.
So sometimes you may just
see this database as NEA.
That's all the databases
that come with JANIS.
If we expand this,
make sure that you
go to incident neutron data.
Because these are cross
sections for neutron reactions
that we want to go for.
And there are a lot
of databases in here.
And in the problem
set, specifically
say to use the most recent ENDF
or evaluated nuclear data file,
just to make sure that we're
all using the same data set.
You'll notice that there are
discrepancies between the data.
So different groups
have measured things
with different uncertainties
and different values.
And so these cross
sections aren't necessarily
fundamental constants of nature.
They're measurements of
those constants with whatever
uncertainty and error, which
are two separate things, that
could be in there.
So let's open up the
most recent ENDF library
and click on cross sections.
And now whatever you see
here, the green squares
are the elements that have
tabulated cross sections.
Just to make sure that we only
have to consider oxygen 16,
let's go to the
table of nuclides.
You'll never stop
using this table.
It's like the most useful
thing in this class.
And check to make
sure that there
is no other stable
isotopes of oxygen
that we have to worry about.
As long as the
internet is working.
Huh.
Did the immigrate to
Korea website crash too?
Interesting.
Well, we'll let
that load for a bit.
And let's start
looking at oxygen 16.
So if you double click on
the element of interest,
it'll usually take a little
while because its Java
and it's loading cross sections.
And then you can pick the
nuclear reaction of choice
from here.
And unfortunately, I can't
easily make this bigger.
I will take a very
quick detour and see
if I can make these things a
bit larger so you can see them.
But if not, then whatever.
No.
Ah, oh, well.
So let's say you wanted to get
the elastic scattering cross
section for oxygen.
The first letter
before the comma is going
to be the incident particle.
Notice that sometimes it says
N and sometimes it says Z. N
specifically means neutrons.
Z means whatever incident
particle you chose.
So we know that here Z means
neutrons coming in and elastic.
That's elastic scattering.
So we can then click
on cross section.
If you want to see what it looks
like, you can check P for plot.
And this will give
you a logarithmic plot
of the scattering cross section
as a function of energy.
You can see that it's
pretty boring for oxygen.
There aren't a lot of nucleons.
There aren't a lot of
different energy levels.
There are not that many
resonances or things going on.
So I wouldn't be that
upset if you just
approximated the fast scattering
cross section for argon
as that value, whatever it is.
But let's do this completely.
Let's tabulate this.
So if you click on T, you
actually get a table of data.
And you can choose how
much data you export.
By default, you
get, like, thousands
upon thousands of entries, which
is just going to make your life
horrible.
So what you can do is either
pick the original values
starting at 1 eV.
And we know we only
have to go up to 10 MeV.
So you can pick your bounds.
And all of a sudden, there
is only a few thousands
worth of data.
Or you can interpolate them.
You can interpolate
values either linearly
or logarithmically--
I recommend logarithmic because
this is such a large energy
range--
and get maybe 5
values per decade.
So between 1 and 10 MeV,
you only need five numbers.
That's still pretty intense.
Oh, I didn't uncheck
the original values.
Ah, isn't that better?
So now there's only
20 or 30 entries.
It glosses over the resonances.
It sure does.
But are they that important?
That's up to you guys to decide.
You can try doing one
of these calculations
with the original values and
with the interpolated values
and see just how different they
really are in two-group theory.
And hint is, not very much.
So then you can actually
export that data.
So either you can
just copy-paste it.
So I just highlighted, copied,
start Excel, and in it comes.
And right there is
the data that you
can start to use to do
your numerical integration.
And I don't want
to give away how
to do the numerical
integration, though I
kind of did, symbolically.
I'd like you guys
to figure out how
to do this numerical integration
mathematically, given
that you can get the data now.
So is there any step here
that's unclear to anyone?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So are we going
to have to go through, like,
every single material, like,
all their different cross
sections to, basically,
sum up and average them?
MICHAEL SHORT: Yes, you are.
Sounds horrible, isn't it?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MICHAEL SHORT: That's why I
made some simplifications.
So if you notice, we are
simplifying the cladding as Zr.
And we're simplifying
stainless steel as pure iron.
I don't want you
guys to just do tons
and tons of repetitive stuff.
But I do want you to get
roughly the right answer.
AUDIENCE: For Uranium, do you
want us to [INAUDIBLE] U-238
versus 235?
MICHAEL SHORT: I want you
to answer that question.
So how would you consider
the isotopes of uranium
in this question?
AUDIENCE: Shouldn't it
be enriched uranium?
MICHAEL SHORT: That's right.
It's not the natural values,
it's the enriched values.
So it will say in
the spec sheet--
AUDIENCE: I don't want to look
up enriched uranium on Google.
MICHAEL SHORT: You don't
want to be on a list?
You don't have to look up
enriched uranium on Google.
You can look it up on JANIS.
So if you go to
JANIS, right, are you
looking for what the
enrichment level is?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MICHAEL SHORT: Oh, that's
on the AP1000 spec sheet.
Where'd it go?
If we search for enrichment,
fuel enrichment, first cycle
weight percent.
You can either average these
or just pretend it's five.
Because that's a pretty
typical enrichment level
is 5% atomic fraction U-235.
Or if you want to
get really technical,
you can average these noting
how many fuel assemblies are
in each of the regions.
But I don't really
care if you do that.
AUDIENCE: What would be
the other [INAUDIBLE]??
MICHAEL SHORT: U-238.
Yeah, so there's
only two isotopes
of uranium, one
of oxygen, however
many of ion and zirconium--
hint there's not that many.
And then there is H2O.
And there's only one
hydrogen and one oxygen.
So it's not really
that much busy work.
It's just enough for you
to get to the right answer.
So I wouldn't even
call it busy work
because there's a point to it.
So in that way,
you can determine
all of these cross sections.
We give you these fluxes.
These new values you
can also get from JANIS.
They're not labeled
as new, but they
are labeled as neutron
multiplication factor.
And they're usually
way down here.
And we probably need to find
a physial isotope for that.
So let's ditch oxygen for
now, and go up to uranium.
OK.
So let's do U-235.
It'll pull up the data.
And then near the bottom, new
bar total, neutron production.
Check it out.
For pretty much all
energies, until you
get to the fast region, it's
the value we talked about--
2.44.
And then in the fast
region, you suddenly
can get more neutrons
from fission.
Why do you guys think that is?
Well, what sort of
additional things
happen when your incident
particle energy increases?
Let's think back to binding
energy and all the stuff
at the beginning of the course.
There's more different
kinds of fission products
that can be made.
Because you're increasing
the Q value of this reaction
by increasing the
initial kinetic energy.
So there are more fission
products that can be made.
And some of them,
let's say, give off
more neutrons than others.
So you'll be able to
get your new bar total
from this one near the bottom.
And everything else
will be near the top.
They'll either be
a fission cross
section, an absorption
cross section, a scattering
cross section.
How do you get your
diffusion coefficients?
They're not tabulated,
but they're close.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, isn't it based
off the numbers based off
the different cross sections
we have [INAUDIBLE]??
MICHAEL SHORT: Yeah.
Exactly.
So let's render this nicely.
The diffusion constant
is 1 over 3 times
the total cross section
minus mu 0 scattering--
average, average, average.
And this average cosine is
about 2/3 times the atomic mass.
So you can get these
diffusion coefficients
from tabulated data.
The total cross section is found
at the top, better known as--
well, it just says total.
So you can get total
cross sections here.
The only one that might
be a little tricky for you
to find from notation
is absorption.
You're not going to
see something labeled
absorption in this database.
However, you will see
this gamma reaction.
Or how else do you get it?
If you take the total minus
fission minus scattering,
you're left with absorption--
if you don't count N2N
reactions or really
esoteric high-energy things.
So if you can't
find it, that's OK.
Because you can calculate it.
Because we know sigma
absorption is sigma total
minus sigma scattering minus
sigma fission minus others
that we don't care about.
And since you're
getting these anyway,
tabulating sigma absorptions
should be trivial.
It's just an Excel subtraction.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I guess
U-235 doesn't have it.
But last night I was
looking at Pu-239.
And it has N in an inelastic.
MICHAEL SHORT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Would that be
considered absorption?
MICHAEL SHORT:
Inelastic scattering
is not considered absorption.
AUDIENCE: OK.
MICHAEL SHORT: So
inelastic scattering
means one neutron
goes in, one neutron
comes out, but at a very
different energy level.
So I guess we would also
say minus sigma inelastic.
And inelastic does happen for
just about every other element.
But the nice thing is,
those don't turn on
until about 1 MeV.
So it's not going
to matter much.
But you can quantify how much
it matters, and just check.
So if you can make a justified
assumption to say here's
one of the calcs with and
without inelastic scattering,
and if they don't
differ by much,
then forget it, as long
as you show me your math.
So let's say we've got nus.
We have cross sections.
I give you fluxes.
We have Ds.
You can calculate
buckling from the geometry
of the reactor, which is given
in the AP1000 spec sheet.
The only other
trick will be what's
sigma scattering
from fast to thermal?
So you'll have to
figure out what
is the cross section, not
just of scattering total,
but the cross section
or the probability
that a fast neutron
enters the thermal group.
And I don't want to
give that away either,
but it's not terribly
mathematical.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So if you only have
one isotope for whatever you're
analyzing, you don't have to go
through the whole overall cross
section.
Can't you just do
the number density
times the number
of cross sections?
Yeah, you don't have to.
MICHAEL SHORT: Hm, not quite.
So even if you only have one
isotope for each material,
if you have more
than one material,
you've got to average
those cross sections.
Because this
criticality criterion
is for the entire reactor
and all the stuff in it.
That's why it's
like in a blender.
So even if iron has one
isotope and zirconium has
one isotope and uranium has one
isotope, which wouldn't really
be a reactor, then
you'd still have
to take atom fractions of those
to get the total criticality
condition.
Speaking of which, I forgot
to write where the K is.
And since everything else
here will be tabulated,
you can solve for k-effective.
So k-effective is the
only variable unknown
in this whole equation.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: But I mean, like,
for one of the other questions,
it's, like, oh, if you had
a perfectly spherical ball
of plutonium-230i, I think
it is, in that situation,
could you just use the
cross sections from JANIS
where you don't have
to account for any kind
of other isotope [INAUDIBLE]?
MICHAEL SHORT: That's right.
So, yeah, let's go to the
rest of the problem set,
since you mentioned it.
For one of the other questions,
North Korean nuclear weapons.
Why is it that just
putting together
a super critical
mass of plutonium
does not constitute
an effective bomb?
We're lucky for that, too,
that making nuclear weapons
is a lot harder than just
getting nuclear material.
And this is a lot of the reason
why theirs have been 500 ton
yields or kiloton yields--
duds.
It's really, really,
really, really hard.
And I want you to think
about what would you
need to do to turn a
super critical mass
of nuclear material into
an effective weapon.
And why is it that it's
so difficult to do?
I'm actually really glad
it's so difficult to do.
It's one of the reasons that a
lot of folks don't have them.
But, yeah, if you
only have one isotope
like you do in this
problem, you don't
have to do atom fractions.
You just take
number density times
microscopic cross
section from JANIS
and you get the
macro cross sections.
That's why it's one of the
skill building problems where
it shouldn't be that hard.
So you'll have a
criticality condition.
You'll be able to get cross
sections and number densities.
And you'll be able to tell
what that radius of the sphere
is given the form of
buckling for a sphere, which
should be in your reading.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Where do we get our
data for power manipulation?
MICHAEL SHORT: That's
being sent to you today.
AUDIENCE: OK.
MICHAEL SHORT: So you guys
all did power manipulations
from the reactor.
I wanted to get them for Monday.
The guys were busy doing an
in-core experiment install.
They've promised
me the data today.
So you guys will be able
to take a look at it,
and using the transient stuff
that we talked about Tuesday,
explain why it doesn't look
linear feedback or intuitive.
Yeah.
So I'll be giving each
of you that data today.
We talked about nuclear weapons.
This top one I want
you to do on your own,
because it's other repetitions
of the intuitive criticality
examples that we did on Tuesday.
The last one we
haven't talked about
is the ultra-cold nuclear
reactor or the "we'll see"
problem.
So here I want you
to actually get
a criticality condition
for the case where you
can have ultra-cold neutrons.
Where your moderator is, let's
say, liquid hydrogen, really,
really cold, way below
the thermal level,
and you have to
split your reactor
into three energy groups--
fast, thermal, and ultra cold.
And the trick to this
here is somebody asked,
can you ever have up-scattering?
Why yes.
If you have an
ultra-cold moderator
but you've got hot fuel, you can
actually scatter up in energy
where the surrounding
atoms could
be hotter than some of
the neutrons hitting it
and will impart energy
to those neutrons
and send it up the
energy spectrum.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
about that, it says
all fission neutrons
are born fast
and all delayed neutrons
are born thermal.
Can there be no up-scattering
from ultra cold?
MICHAEL SHORT: Well how do
you get ultra cold neutrons?
AUDIENCE: They
would scatter down.
MICHAEL SHORT: Mm-hm.
But some of them
might scatter up.
AUDIENCE: OK, got it.
MICHAEL SHORT: Yeah,
they can scatter down
by hitting something cold and
scatter back up by getting
knocked by a hot atom.
AUDIENCE: OK.
MICHAEL SHORT: Yeah.
So it's all going to be in the
formulation of the equations.
For this problem, like
80% or 85% of the credit
is, did you formulate
the three-group equations
correctly.
So I want you to think about
what are the actual sources
and sinks in each case,
what are the fractions
of prompt and delayed
neutrons, where did they go,
and what terms matter where.
So it's doing this, but for the
case that we've given you here.
Solving it is a lot of algebra,
and therefore not a lot
of credit.
So is that clear to everybody?
I figured this p-set was worth
explaining and not just saying,
have fun.
You know, I'll see you
on Piazza Sunday night.
AUDIENCE: I'm there.
MICHAEL SHORT: Yeah, that's
why I would check it.
Yeah.
Cool.
I've also got problem set
four for everybody here.
I want to mention a
couple of quick things.
Please, if you hand write
your p-sets, which is fine,
please make sure to scan them
legibly and to write legibly.
We can't give partial credit
for things we can't read.
And so this will be a
lesson to some of you guys
depending on who got what grade.
There are times when
you may have written
stuff for partial credit,
but we just honestly
couldn't make it out.
So please do make sure that
your submissions are legible.
And for things like these, these
are handwritten problem sets,
but they were scanned with
either a scanner which
does the correct
contrast or writing them
on one note, which
apparently works pretty well,
or apps like CamScanner.
There's an app on
your phone you can
get that scans pieces of paper
and automatically contrast
enhances them.
It knows the paper
should be white
and the writing should be black.
And it also does it in color.
So if you do color
graphs, it recognizes
that there are multiple
colors and will
take care of that for you.
It only takes an
additional minute,
but it can give you double
the points on a problem set
because we can read stuff.
So I'll give back
p-set four now.
We're working on five and six.
The big delay in grading
there was I went to Russia.
And Russia doesn't have
as much internet as we do,
at least not where I was.
And it was busy.
So working on those
solutions now.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: For
problem one, it says
throwing quarters into the
reactor actually happened.
MICHAEL SHORT: Yep.
AUDIENCE: When did that happen?
MICHAEL SHORT: Oh, OK,
yeah, good question.
So problem 1, throwing
quarters directly into the core
like a wishing well.
It used to be that
back in the day,
they would take folks
on reactor tours
to look down into the core.
Because when the lid
is off, you can see it.
You can see the Cherenkov
radiation, the nice blue light.
You can actually see
the fuel elements
because the water is
sufficient shielding for you.
And the distance is sufficient
shielding to keep you away
from the gammas, not to mention
the reactor is usually off
when the lid is off.
So it's not that hot.
The problem is you
can't watch what
everyone's doing all the time.
And somebody dropped a
quarter into the reactor.
And they were like, oh,
it's a wishing well.
Well, it took something like six
dive robots to go into the core
and fish it out.
Because each of those
robots lasts 10 minutes
before the intense
radiation fries it.
And if you didn't
find the quarter,
you got to take him out,
put down another one.
And these are, like,
radiation-hard, you know,
narrow, whatever, diving robots.
This story was relayed to me
through someone that relayed it
to them through whatever.
So it's been through
the telephone chain.
But I do know that's one of the
big reasons you can't look down
in the core anymore.
It's because folks abuse
the privileges of tourists.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: JANIS 4 just
doesn't work for me.
Like, I have my installed Java.
It's like up to date and stuff.
But it just doesn't work.
MICHAEL SHORT: Interesting.
AUDIENCE: What do you
think I should do?
MICHAEL SHORT: Then you
could use the web version.
AUDIENCE: OK.
MICHAEL SHORT: Which
is just for the browser
and no plugins required.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHAEL SHORT: Cool.
Any other questions
about the p-set
that we didn't cover together?
Those looking a
little more doable?
AUDIENCE: [EXHALES]